i guess everything's okay
i made it this far right
what's the point
toby why don't you open your present no
no no no no no no no this hey hey hey
hey this might not be what i think
that i don't even know is in there
because there are a lot of presents in
my car and i don't know which is which
suck on this
what the hell is that michael that's
what do you mean michael
that's not even my handwriting hey
what the hell is going on here
who thought it would be hysterical to
give toby a rock
for his going away gift you did no you
made me wrap it no i thought it was over
the line
how could you give up my diary like that
i had to i'm sorry but i need to win
this we need to win this how'd you even
find it
you keep it under my side of the
mattress i don't like lump i'm really
upset about this all right i stole your
diary and gave it to my lawyer you
emailed a topless photo of me to
everyone in our company i'm looking at a
photo right now
and i'm telling you it could be in maxim
they wouldn't give you a subscription to
maxim oh no
no okay
well
check this out
i am sending you
some email
you got it what no i got
nothing check it again hit refresh
yeah mike still nothing
okay wait a second i sent it to you
at
packer dunder mifflin.com
packaging
oh oh
wait
i just got it from somebody else
wow
this is hot damn
how do i get you out of this picture
i have a few things to say to you and
please don't interrupt i wasn't going to
interrupt you do a lot so just don't
thank you i know that i haven't always
treated you the way that you for
whatever reason feel you deserve to be
treated
but i want to marry you kelly kapoor
maybe not today maybe not tomorrow
but someday
and probably barf
oh you suck are you feeling better no
well you're the cutest button
you worked up quite a sweat is removing
all of sprinkles organs right now and
sending them to the lab
i am a farmer angela what does that mean
okay when a farmer sees an animal that
is in pain that has no quality of life
that has no utility a farmer does what
city folk don't have the stomach to do
you didn't kill her oh hey do you uh
do you like the jamie kennedy experiment
yeah and punk'd and all that kind of
stuff okay
um you are going to be my accomplice
just go along with it okay all right
just follow my lead don't pimp me all
right come in
so uh corporate just said that i don't
want to oh thank you pam pam can you
come in here for a sec
just have a seat i was gonna call you in
anyway um
you know ryan
um
as you know
there's going to be downsizing and uh
you have made my life
so much easier
in that i am going to have to let you go
first
what why
why well theft
and stealing
stealing um
what am i supposed to have stolen
post-it notes
post-it notes yeah okay what are those
worth like 50 cents 50 cents yeah you
steal a thousand post-it notes at 50
cents a piece and you know you've made a
profit
margin you know go
run us out of business pam
are you serious
yeah i am
um
i can't believe this i mean i've never
even stolen as much as a paper clip and
now you're firing me
but the best thing about it is that uh
we're not gonna have to give you any
severance pay
because that is
gross misconduct and uh i just clean out
your desk i'm sorry
you've been ex-punk
[Laughter]
surprise it's a joke we were joking
around
let's see
okay he was in on it he was my
accomplice and
there was just kind of a morale booster
thing and we were
showing the new guy around kind of
kind of giving him the feel of the place
so
you
god you were we totally got you're a
jerk
i don't know about that
there are a lot of different ways to get
revenge i've had great success by
defecating in a paper bag better than
the very effective i've been on the
receiving end of that quite a few times
it's definitely no no no it has to be
physical i want this person to suffer
what about a kneecapping no no you're
not helping trevor yes and kneecapping
could work
in prison you are somebody's [ __ ] oh
and you you my friend would be the belle
of the ball don't drop the soap don't
drop the soap michael please
albert
hey uh i uh you know heard there's a
rumor going around about you know you
used to have a crush on pam oh no no no
no it's it's cool because i know you're
a good guy and i know that that crush
ended a long time ago so you know
we're cool right
yeah nope yeah definitely you know i'm
it's great with me because wait
glad she has a friend at work she can
get through the day with oh she's done
all that bad bad you know when she gets
home yeah i like talking to her too i
guess there are just some people who
you stay together with when you transfer
and some people you don't and that's
just the way it is
and i can be mature about that
oh
[Laughter]
surprise it was part of the party
pretty funny huh you think this is funny
i don't
but someday i think we will laugh about
this
when we tell our kids yikes
oh
okay that's nice
[Music]
to make things simpler for d'angelo i
just without lying strongly implied that
i'm kelly's supervisor it's not even
that much of a stretch she pretty much
does whatever i say hey kelly kapoor if
i don't have those call logs on my desk
we're just gonna have to evaluate your
future of the company
sure thing mr howard whoo
glad he's not my boss
you're the best thank you
oh thank you pam and i hope you were as
gracious during
this next part
helene once again you are a wonderful
person and you have lived a great life
and i envy it and i want it someday but
just in the future
you need somebody who who understands
your references who is kafkaesque i've
never i don't know him
there's another woman
and her name is italy and skydiving and
bungee jumping okay so and i want kids
and you unfortunately have already
completed that part of your journey down
there michael it's not my decision it's
mother nature and mother has very strict
rules about fruits
fertility i don't get it how could she
be sleeping with you this whole time
only sleep with me twice
what what
she's sleeping with you
i don't feel today
she said she was only sleeping with me
do you think that'll ever be us
no
what is wrong with you why did you even
bring me here tonight
i don't know
let's break up
what what
what kind of music are you into peter
uh i like all kinds of music gabe really
all kinds so you like songs of hate
written by the white knights of the ku
klux klan no aaron are you even hearing
this he didn't even say that he's not a
very sophisticated man i mean he can't
use chopsticks so do i need to say
anything else
erin
i've been to japan i know how to use
chopsticks so well
come back
one night give me one night what is that
supposed to be is that good i don't want
you to show
why don't you say at the beginning this
isn't really going that well you shovel
his sashimi into his mouth with the
support
all right all right yes that is a
legitimate question does making aaron
and pete feel bad make me feel better
yeah
yeah
it does
you